tim you're on the air what up in rhode
island did jd cry over cincinnati
bengals dude
this is why this is the best show on
radio
we sent over a producer to just record
jd during the entire bengals game really
[ __ ] it's the greatest tape wait till
you [ __ ] hear this guy i don't know
what's wrong with him jd you know i love
jd don't get me wrong he cried but even
his crying is weird it's very silence of
the lambs
oh my god he got it
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it keeps going robin
it's not over
we're only halfway through it [ __ ]
oh my god
[Music]
he sounded kind of like tickle me elmo a
bit a lot of built up emotions there i
understand his emotions the thing is i
think tiers are saved for the super bowl
win like they still got to win two more
games they somehow win the super bowl i
don't know what the hell the [ __ ]
i'll react he'll be crazy right he's
been crying at every one of these games
john you were there watching observing
jd in his natural habitat during the big
game any observations you want to share
with us he's so connected he's one with
this team he's rocking back and forth
like a maniac and then he gets up to the
screen and he's two inches from the
screen hunched in screaming like a
maniac i did not want the team to lose
because it would have been a dark knight
richard christie's a big chiefs guy
we're coming for you jg
bingles are going down
you must have been uh shocked by this oh
my god howard it is the
i'm gonna
cry he's gonna cry the greatest football
game i've ever seen in my life and
my homes
they had 13 seconds left in regulation
mahomes only needed 10 out of those 13
[ __ ] seconds to drive down the field
with two throws
and get a field goal to tie it and send
it into [ __ ] overtime it was
[ __ ] unreal i still cannot [ __ ]
believe that that happened it made me so
[ __ ] happy
you're dressed as an assistant coach
right now right
as if you worked for the chiefs
organization is that correct yeah now
will you be dressed like this until the
super bowl if they get that far of
course this jersey is not coming off
robin i'm going to shower
well how dirty is that hat oh it's
healthy
hey a real fan never washes their hat
like if you have a filthy old dirty hat
you know like that that person has been
a fan for a long time like i have a
royals hat that's ancient that's covered
in all kinds of gross stains and stuff
and people i get compliments on it from
royals fans they're like dude you're old
school let's cut to the important
question uh richard you're passionate
about kansas city jd do you want to get
into a betting thing with him or do you
just want to avoid all bets whatsoever
do you want to bet the bengals and the
chiefs i don't care i'll i'll bet
richard if you lose you got to burn that
kansas city [ __ ] hat and new jersey
the hat has so much history and
i'm very sentimental i've worn this hat
when i've watched games with my dad and
i can't even think of parting with it
it's gonna hurt me but uh it'd be worth
it if i get to see jd's [ __ ]
[Laughter]
everything involves the [ __ ] with the
richard i don't know what it is jd if
you lose richard gets to stare at your
dick for 60 seconds if no one else is
seeing my dick and it's just richard's
fine whatever oh
there we go wow jd you really believe in
your team you're going to show your dick
to richard start fluffing
you'll get what you get all right
let's be fair about this too when you
show them your [ __ ] i mean you got to
give them a good view of [ __ ] and balls
i mean you can't like do some ridiculous
camera angle
right here straight on view and i'll
make sure he gets whatever view he
needs i think his legs should be behind
his head it's like i'm on full [ __ ]
too
he didn't he didn't say he'd do the ass
that's a different bet yeah that's for
next super bowl